a CT scan also known as a cat scan or
computerized axial tomography is a
painless diagnostic test that uses
x-rays and computers to create
cross-sectional images of bones and
tissues inside your body your doctor may
recommend a CT scan to examine your body
for any of the following blood clots
broken bones
cancerous tumors
infections
internal injuries and bleeding
and signs of heart and vascular disease
a CT scan helps your doctor select the
correct location for surgery biopsy or
radiation therapy check the treatment of
cancer or heart disease and check your
condition after surgery
a CT scanner is a large square or round
x-ray machine with a tunnel through the
center during your CT scan you will lie
on a table that slowly passes through
the tunnel as you move through the
tunnel a giant ring called a gantry will
rotate around your body the gantry
contains a tube that will release x-ray
beams and detectors that will measure
the amount of radiation absorbed by your
body the x-ray beams will capture many
views of your body from different angles
as the gantry spins the detectors will
send data to a computer that will create
cross-sectional images of the bones and
soft tissues inside your body the scan
allows your doctor to see the location
of a condition inside your body which
will help them decide how to treat it or
to see how well your treatment is
progressing in some cases you may
receive contrast dye before your
procedure in a drink an injection or a
barium enema to make it easier for your
doctor to see certain areas of your body
if you received a drink with contrast
dye your esophagus or stomach will be
highlighted
if you received an injection your blood
vessels gallbladder liver or urinary
tract will be highlighted
if you received a barium enema your
large intestine will be highlighted
after the procedure you can resume your
normal activities if you received
contrast I drink plenty of fluids to
help your kidneys remove the dye from
your body